It's really important that I do this story
today before we get sucked into really unreasonable
and naive expectations about how the next
couple of years are going to go.
We need to reset our expectations for the
next couple of years, and this should help.
Some have been wondering, some have been asking
me, emailing me, David, what happens to these
anti Trump Republicans when Joe Biden wins?
What happens to the Lincoln Project?
What happens to the Kazik?
What happens to Romney?
Do they keep working with Democrats?
Do they support Biden's agenda?
What happens?
And the answer is no to all of the above.
I have two quick clips to play for you today,
which will, in no time at all, disabuse you
of the notion that these anti Trump Republicans
are our friends.
Now, to be very clear, if you take an anti
Trump Republican and you remove Trump, what
do you have left?
It's called the Republican, OK?
They become just Republicans.
When you remove Trump from the equation.
Here is Mitt Romney.
Strong, principled, anti Trump Republican.
Right.
Telling Jake Tapper on CNN his priorities
now that Trump Reagan are blocking the green
new deal, keeping gas, coal and oil and blocking
Medicare for all and blocking any tax increases.
Take a look.
I'm not going to talk about my vote.
That's in the rearview mirror.
I'm going to talk now about how I can work
with the new president.
I know he's on the other side of the aisle,
but I want to make sure that we conservatives
keep on fighting to make sure that we don't
have a green new deal.
We don't get rid of gas and coal and oil,
that we don't have a Medicare for all plan
put in place.
So we don't raise taxes on American enterprise
that would kill the economy.
So, look, I congratulate him, but I'm not
going to put aside conservative principles.
We're going to fight for the things that we
believe in.
So he was against Trump.
Principled voted even to convict Trump on
impeachment on one of the two counts, and
his policies are still awful and now his priority
is blocking the things that Joe Biden says
he's going to do.
Mitt Romney, now that Joe Biden will be president,
immediately returns to making his focus, preventing
us from putting policies in place that would
be good for the environment and good for people
and good for the economy.
These are not our friends.
And I was wrong because I previously said
the day Biden is inaugurated, they go back
to being their nonsensical selves.
I underestimated the day after Biden was called
the winner, they went back to being their
nonsensical selves.
Here's another one.
Reasonable anti Trump Republican John Kasich
supported Biden.
He goes on CNN and says, Joe Biden one.
Great.
Now Biden needs to do what Republicans want
and make sure that the left of the Democratic
Party isn't listened to.
And Kasich even goes on to say that the far
left almost cost Biden the election.
And right on cue, I have joked that they would
do this.
John Kasich actually brings up you know, we've
got big debt problems to solve.
It is beyond parody.
I told you, you're ready for them to talk
about the debt again.
Right.
And and right on cue, John Kasich is doing
it.
Now is the time for Democrats.
And I believe Joe Biden will do this to begin
to listen to what the other half the country
has had to say.
But we have to listen to what those folks,
those Republicans all across this country
has had to say.
The best thing that's happened to Joe Biden
is the fact that the United States Senate
is either going to be Republican or very close
and the far left can push him as hard as they
want.
And frankly, the Democrats have to make it
clear to the far left that they almost cost
him this election.
And that congresswoman from Virginia warned
the Democrats, you want to talk about defunding
the police, you'll have no support.
And I think this is an opportunity for Biden
to talk about, you know, the center right
and the center left of this country and what
can be achieved because we have enormous problems
with debt, Social Security, Medicare, health
care, little steps, little steps.
One other thing, one Democrat told me at some
point, if they have been more clear in rejecting
the hard left, they would have appealed more
to Americans who I believe essentially live
in the middle.
So I think actually he's in a better position
today because being pulled from the left isn't
going to work.
So they are doing every single thing that
Republicans always do.
They've learned nothing.
They've changed nothing from this Trump experience
during Trump.
Some of them oppose Trump.
Biden wins now.
It's resist the influence from the hard left.
We've got to deal with the debt.
We've got to find common ground, which, by
the way, when they win, they never have to
find common ground, common ground they want
when they lose.
Democrats have catered to the middle, like
Kasich says, for decades.
And now Biden won thanks to the activism of
the left in places like Georgia and others.
So the last thing Joe Biden should be doing
is listening to the people.
First of all, he shouldn't be listening to
Kasich or Romney, and he certainly shouldn't
be listening to the people Kasich and Romney
want Biden to listen to.
It's I have like whiplash from how quickly
these Republicans go right back to their tired
old lines.
I told you it would happen.
And it has.